what do we do with all the milk from our family dairy cow
welcome to the series that explains what we do daily with about a gallon of milk
when our Cora first in latation
should bring us four to five gallons of milk a day
right now she's in about the 18th month of lactation
so he's given us a solid gallon
a gallon a half a day
so with our family we could probably drink about a gallon of milk a day
but I also still make lots of different things with our milk
today I'm gonna make some rice pudding
I ate this a lot as a child
but it always came from a can
so it's interesting to make my own
and I start with some milk
I'm did skim the cream off the top of this milk
I added a cup of sugar a half a cup of rice
and a little bit of salt this pink Himalayan salt is really kinda strong
so I cannot wait to put less salt in
because a little bit too salty
I'm gonna let that boil down and simmer for about an hour
and then I added in a little bit more cream
because this actually boiled over and spilt milk everywhere
so it needs a little bit more liquid content to it
so I added a little bit more cream on top
and then I added some canned jam that I canned in the spring and it was delish